you know the results of Zoey's MRI or  will she ever have to get another one to  get a diagnosis for what was bothering  her so she gets a it was cut out of the  pilot but there is a scene in the pilot  pilot that we shot where he calls and  he's like there's nothing wrong wrong  with your brain and she's like are you  sure and Max is in the elevator he's  like are you okay and I'm like uh-huh  and for some reason I think timing  probably it was cut so we the there's no  the doctor doesn't know what's wrong but  we saw some fishy business and the  finale where he was whistling I've got  the music in me so I'm expecting some  answers in season two Austin